TV PRICES:
In our inflationary world filled with fiat
currencies and money printing, increasing
prices is simply a reality of daily life.
Whether you’re trying to buy a house, a
cup of coffee, or a nice meal, you can bet
that prices are only gonna go up over the
long term. In the 1960s for example, a big
mac only cost 45 cents. Today, a big mac costs
over 10 times that at $4.95. This trend is
especially true in the world of new tech where
companies are constantly trying to create
the next big thing and charge as much as possible.
However, in this universe of inflation, there
is one notable exception: TVs. Even if you
don’t follow TV prices too closely, you’ve
probably noticed TV prices creeping down whenever
you stroll by them at Costco or Best Buy.
Nowadays, you can get 4K TVs for as little
as $200 and 85 inch 4K TVs for just $800 or
for less than the price of a flagship smartphone.
Just 10 years ago, both of these would’ve
costed you thousands of dollars. But is this
just a case of new TV tech becoming cheaper
or are TV prices actually falling across the
board? Well, if you take a look at the historical
price of TVs, it becomes clear that it’s
very much the latter. Basically since 1950,
TVs have been consistently falling in prices.
There have been a few years here and there
where they went up but most of those years
had inflation that was even higher. So, the
real prices of TVs were still going down.
This trend has only accelerated over the past
20 years during which TVs have been consistently
falling by 15% or more every single year.
At the same time, TVs have been consistently
getting bigger and better as well. At the
turn of the century, the average TV was only
24 inches. Today, the average TV is 50 inches.
We’ve also gone from plasma TVs to LCDs
to LEDs to OLEDs, QLEDs, neo QLEDs, mini LEDS,
and who knows what else. Not to mention, resolutions
seem to be endlessly going up. So, somehow,
we’re able to get bigger and better TVs
than ever for a lot cheaper than ever. So,
here’s the inexplicable economics of TVs
and how TV prices keep falling into a seemingly
endless abyss.
ADOPTION DELAY:
Taking a look back, the phenomenon of TVs
falling in prices can be traced all the way
back to the beginning of TVs themselves. Well,
technically, the technology used in TVs can
actually be traced back to the early 1800s,
but we’re more focused on modern commercial
TVs which take us back to September of 1928.
This is when the first commercially produced
television set was shown off to the public.
This, however, was terrible timing as the
Great Depression hit just one year later making
it extremely difficult to introduce new consumer
tech into the market. In fact, it would take
a full 10 years for this demonstration to
turn into a widely available product. But,
it was worth the wait given that it would
become a instant success, but things were
just getting started. It wasn’t till after
World War 2 and after America entered a new
age of prosperity and economic growth that
people started splurging on homes, cars, and
of course TVs. But not only were TV sales
going to the moon, so was TV tech. Starting
in 1946, we would see a heated race between
CBS and RCA to bring color TVs into every
household. CBS would end up beating RCA to
market but not without making a massive sacrifice.
The color television sets that CBS came up
with weren't compatible with the black and
white TV sets that millions of Americans already
had. Nonetheless, the FCC would declare CBS
color TVs as being the new national standard.
Instead of fighting against the FCC on this
decision though, RCA would simply continue
developing a more compatible color TV standard.
And the FCC would eventually concede that
RCA’s design was much more practical making
them the new standard in 1953. It was a classic
case of the better invention coming out on
top, but honestly, none of this really mattered.
It wasn’t till 13 years later in 1966 when
color TV broadcasting became more popular
that people actually started buying color
TVs. And this brings us into the first unique
factor of the TV market which is that it has
always had a massive adoption delay. The first
commercial TV was created in the late 1920s
but it didn’t take off till the 1940s. The
first color TVs started popping up in the
late 40s and early 50s, but they didn’t
really gain steam till the late 60s. And it’s
the same case to this day. OLED for example
was created in the late 1980s and it first
started showing up in TVs in 2004. But, it’s
only now that the general public is buying
into OLED and even now, there’s still a
lot of room for growth. For whatever reason,
people are willing to be extremely patient
with TVs which is in stark contrast to any
other tech industry. Take smartphones for
example. 5G didn’t even start getting deployed
till 2018 and 2019, and it wasn’t till the
2020s that it was actually widely available.
Yet, by the end of 2022 itself, over a 100
million Americans or about a ⅓ of the country
already had 5G. With most tech industries,
people want the absolutely latest and greatest.
They’re often reluctant to buy something
even 2 or 3 generations old but it’s the
complete opposite with TVs. People are not
only willing to buy 5-7 year old tech but
they’re also happy to diss on new tech.
Just 10 years ago, it was extremely popular
to hate on 4k. The common belief seemed to
be that you couldn’t even tell a difference
between 1080p and 4k and that 4k was waste
of money. That was until 4k became dirt cheap
and people completely forgot about their concerns
and picked up a 4k TV. The same thing is happening
with 8k as we speak. Who even needs 8k? You
can’t even tell the difference. 8k is so
stupid. There’s not even any 8k content
and on and on and on. It’s actually crazy
how heated people get over new TV tech. The
reality is that if you have an 85 or 98 inch
TV which are increasingly becoming the norm,
you can tell a difference between 4k and 8k.
Just not a difference that’s worth an extra
3 to $4000. If you give it 5 to 10 years though
and wait for 8k TV prices to become comparable
to 4k TV prices, and you can bet that the
general public will forget all about their
concerns and buy an 8k TV. And honestly that’s
great. People are happy to buy the new TV
tech when its offered at a reasonable price.
But until then, they’re somehow completely
immune to marketing hype. If consumers approached
every industry with this mindset, credit card
debt wouldn’t even be thing, but unfortunately,
this magical consumer clarity only applies
to the TV industry which brings us into the
question of why?
CONSUMER CLARITY:
Trying to answer why consumers aren’t moved
by TV marketing is a rather tough question
to answer. The obvious explanation is that
TVs are a matured market that isn’t progressing
all that quickly. So, it’s easy for consumers
to settle on something that’s a bit older
but that’s not really true. There’s quite
a big difference between regular LED TVs and
OLED TVs. Definitely a much bigger difference
than the iPhone 12 vs the iPhone 15. Yet,
I feel that it would be much easier to convince
someone to hold back and buy an LED TV than
it would be to get them to buy an iPhone 12.
And it’s not just with smartphones either.
I could maket the same argument with cars.
Assuming that all prices were the same, it
would be much harder to convince someone to
buy a 10 year old car than buy an LED TV,
and cars don’t even change. And this brings
me into one of the most basic marketing rules:
features don’t sell products. Automakers
and Apple understand this perfectly. TV makers
do not. For decades, TV makers have been trying
to push TVs based on new tech whether that
be OLED or 8k or whatever. Consumers aren’t
really moved by features though. They’re
moved by apparent change. For example, unless
your a TV nerd, you probably don’t know
the difference between OLED, QLED, neo QLED,
and mini LED. But, regardless of how knowledgeable
you are on TVs, I bet you remember when TVs
went from being boxes to being flat or when
they went from being 24 inches to being 85
inches. These sort of changes may not actually
make that big of a difference to picture quality
compared to LED vs OLED. In fact, bigger TVs
usually have worse picture quality. But, nonetheless,
they’re often much more compelling reasons
to upgrade. If everyone around you has upgraded
from box TVs to flat screen TVs or from 55
inch TVs to 85 inch TVs, you’d probably
wanna upgrade as well. This is precisely the
formula that automakers leverage. Every couple
of years, automakers will change up the design
of their cars just to keep things feeling
fresh and new. This way, by the time your
current car is 10 to 15 years old, even if
it’s working perfectly fine, it’ll feel
old and outdated. It’s the same case with
Apple. With every generation, they try to
add something that makes it distinctly clear
that it’s the new one. For example, iPhones
that still have home buttons definitely feel
outdated. iPhones with notches as opposed
to dynamic islands are even starting to feel
outdated despite it being a non material difference.
At this point, there’s not much more that
can change with the iPhone’s design and
that’s why Apple is dragging those out for
as long as possible. Things like removing
the dynamic island or camera bump altogether.
With TVs, on the other hand, they’ve basically
always been in their final form. It’s only
a few times in history that the design has
fundamentally changed at which points people
did upgrade quickly. But putting those instances
aside, there’s really no obvious difference
between any of the new TV standards. Sure,
they’re better and you want it, but unless
you put them side by side, you wouldn’t
even notice a difference. So, people are able
to be surprisingly patient when it comes to
new TV tech and they don’t particularly
feel left behind or left out either leading
to astounding consumer clarity. But while
this is great for consumers, it sucks for
TV makers leading to some pretty odd solutions.
FORCING CHANGE:
Given this consumer sentiment, TV makers have
been trying to introduce material changes
as regularly as possible but most of this
efforts end up falling flat. For example,
remember that time that TVs went from being
flat to being curved to being flat again?
Or what about that time that 3d TVs were supposedly
the next big thing. The reality is that it’s
extremely difficult to force changes like
these unless you’re Apple and over the years,
TV makers have come to accept this reality.
Instead, they’ve turned their attention
to alternative modes of monetization like
data collection. It turns out that you’re
viewing habits are extremely valuable to streaming
services like Netflix and Disney+. So, TV
makers no longer even need to make money when
you buy the TV. Instead, they make their money
in the following 5-10 years selling your data
to streaming giants. In fact, the average
margin across the TV industry is only 6% and
that’s with the stupid expensive 8k OLED
TVs pulling that margin up. So, if you buy
a regular TV with a strong discount on Black
Friday or Christmas, there’s a good chance
that you got that TV at cost or even under
cost. Larger brands like LG and Samsung don’t
even care all that much about post purchase
monetization either. For them, the TV industry
has become something that they use to simply
maximize brand presence and dominance as opposed
to really making money. So, why do TV prices
keep going down? Well, you’ve of course
got all of your classic stuff like economies
of scale, the commoditization of TVs, new
tech making old tech cheaper, and all that
jazz. But the real bottom line is that the
general public doesn’t buy into TV marketing
hype. So, after TV makers burn through the
rich buyers who can afford to burn a couple
grand, they’re forced to quickly decrease
prices to appeal to a much broader audience.
Some TV makers have figured out alternative
modes of monetization but for the most part,
TVs have become a near 0 margin industry that
companies just use to stay relevant and omnipresent
resulting in TV prices falling forever. Samsung
is starting to feel this same squeeze within
the smartphone industry as we enter the era
of peak smartphone. Check out this video to
learn more.